i've found three goals already what are
my dates
oh this year
it was a recent one francisco
what a friend my friends
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to relationship goals i'm theo
johnson your host and i'm with a12 funny
this guy is gonna be the judge jewelry
and executioner relationship goals is a
tournament where coppers go head to head
to see who's got the most solid couple
if they win this they go to the
semi-final if they win at the semi-final
they go to the final and if they win the
final
jordan ruby
even though this money you know
but more importantly as my judge is
demonstrating they win a hundred free
firewave pizzas
and whoever wins just know about me and
them was friends from time to go i'm
saying let's hope
i'm gonna try and blow it in switch open
that anyway let's go and my name is mara
my name is jahin
and we need to compete with our couples
my name is princess and i review my
babies evan uh we've been in a
relationship for almost four years four
years now yeah i would say free
yeah
it's your partner the one
yes yes
that's the show um
i bet
well i won't know rely on until like
that kind of comes until he you know
pops the question do you argue alone
yeah yeah
especially because um his long distance
relationship sometimes
[Music]
all right so round one ladies i'm gonna
have to ask you to go into the
soundproof section because i gotta ask
your boyfriend some questions and see if
they can predict what you would say can
you guys hear me
can you guys hear me yeah ladies
ladies perfect first question how of
your girlfriend's family members
which one would you say is the penis
you know when you can envision he's
seeing sarah with her back after that
you know what he's chilling when he's
misses and sarah walks through the night
here all right
hello
wait whoa whoa whoa little girl
[Music]
all right so she's above the legal age
so you're going to say little
bros
i have to team justin
yeah
who's that
sir
so if you're going to jail
what would the crime be why would she be
in jail i'm going to ask you first
[ __ ]
you say i'm fine
just straight fighters just give me
a chance
you know what stereotype i'm not afraid
afraid
he knows he's crying he's crying i came
in
a good place
what about you
if she catches your chin
she's definitely good
so
what would the crime be
m something for you for m you for
cheating
double harbor side yeah
me and then
that bread
i'll call it jealous
okay
last but not least
if you could change one thing about your
girlfriend
just one thing
what would it be i'm going to ask you
the question
i stress
that stress
she stresses her life way too much i was
saying that exactly still
anxiety yeah i should die
obviously
from the ptsd from when you that was
rubbing backs
oh sorry
enjoying
the wings whilst listening to music
we asked your boyfriends a few questions
and
i wanna see um if you know what they
would have said first question we asked
was which one of your family members
would he think he's pain i'm gonna go
with my
purse probably my cousin what's her name
kelly
okay
and what makes you say that
she looks like me
that's my baby
all right
what do you think you all mentioned we
asked welcome to your family members i
think you said my cousin as well sofia
sophia
[Music]
hey i can tell you that kelly was
correct
but sabina was wrong
he said um
hello
jc ain't my family what is
accidentally
question two
we wanted to find out like your
temperament whether your boyfriend is
scared of you or not so we asked
if you guys went to jail
what would it be for
something to deal with violence
something to do something like that in
my head i'm thinking like whenever i
restaurant they get all the wrong and it
escalates
where
they get her all along you know
so what's the answer so would you say
yes
okay cool i asked your boyfriend if you
was to end up in germany yeah what would
it be for
i have anger issues so probably you can
cheat on me okay there seems to be a
trend of angry women here blood bear
raps and like that that's fair
yes and and i've named the men
me yeah i mean yeah yeah we do yeah it's
men's fault yeah you guys whatever
happens
yeah yeah
[Applause]
don't get killed for nash all right then
i can confirm that
both ears
was correct in that one
guys
yeah
we're well protected today
question three
this one might touch nerve a little bit
but i feel like the answer well i feel
like your boyfriend had your back
because we've had some mean people on
the show yes we asked what's the one
thing your boyfriend would change about
you
and
what do you think he had to princess i'm
gonna go to this but physically or like
yeah so one thing will change
it's the way she looks at him as well
she don't she don't do this to him you
know she does she just goes she she uses
a different kind of different muscle to
swing the neck
i think my mouth
your mouth yeah also basically what that
mouth do
you want to change that oh
[Applause]
[Music]
word would you say cat itching yeah
outside if you could change one thing
about you what would it be
i'm still going so probably down
stubborn yeah
is
[Laughter]
so for that round
you said
stubborn yeah
the right answer was stress
he cares about
yeah he was being nice that's what i'm
saying he had your back still and
princess
he was thinking about your anxiety
he even said he had matching anxiety
yeah he said he was like all from ptsd
from where news that was out here in
these streets
for the for the challenges
[Music]
so
could you go into the soundproof section
because
i want to leave these ladies alone with
a1 i mean i'm gonna leave these ladies
um
here while
don't worry that's they'll be safe with
me
so the men are off disease set
headphones eating that firewall pizza
shout out to friends again
if
god forbid of course
you guys broke up
what excellent [ __ ] boyfriend would
go back to
i'm gonna ask princess first i think he
has excellence oh because you've killed
all right
i just don't think he has access
all right what what sneaky link then um
you can just say her name
the ratchet goes right here
uh
okay what's her name oh no
uh so we'll just call that sun [ __ ] and
i'll put an accent over there yeah it's
french
take some [ __ ]
who's a salon
with a sprinkle of frog
it legs if he answers some [ __ ] this
show is magical
i know it's not going to happen but if
he does he says in french and the
geniuses
all right question two
what's the one thing
that you nearly left your boyfriend for
oh
talking to other [ __ ]
and let's get you the accent
okay so what happened when you saw that
he was talking to other bishops
oh i'm getting mad oh you got mad that's
it
what's the one thing you left your
boyfriend
because he wasn't trying to like
spoil me i guess
well that provides to like satisfy me
he wasn't provided enough
so he was looking at an f man in it yeah
you she was dating a man with the glees
and that everybody
was buying out liberty and that and it
come to him and he was trying to take
her nando's and she was like
and then she boxed up the waiters and
then well that's why
she got banned from nando's
not but if you're with someone from like
the semi pose and then someone from the
premier league kind of runs
the
on look at fashions
did you hear what she said send me
prostitutes a bit all right so question
three i want you like to look at each
other
oh that's nice the reason why i'm
telling you is to look at each other
because i want you to look at each other
and tell me
what part of the other person
do you feel like your boyfriend would be
attracted to like what's her best
feature what do you think her boyfriend
oh
it's all smiles and games into the
middle answer that's what i'm going to
say
we are laughing
sometimes we laugh sometimes we cry
[Laughter]
men
can you put down the z-tech headphones
and come here please
firstly
we asked your girlfriends
if user was to ever break up obviously
god forbid
what ex or sneaky league would you
return to
i'm going to ask you first my guy
what do you think your girlfriend said i
think i think she said my ex
what's your next name
oh fairy
princess what do you think princess then
i got the lessons the soul
that goes for that
song
so nobody no
all right cool
so
welcome guys because both of you is got
it right
sorry i'd like to reveal
that's the answer over here um in the
french house was
sarah
sarah
saluki
oh sorry
and you know that translates to my guy
[ __ ]
[Applause]
why do they always move
i ain't pushing anything out of you
you said the rap okay so with question
two what was the one thing you guys did
when you messed up of me and your girl
nearly left you go with e-man first
probably when
[Music]
what
is
myself
[Music]
you said when you cheated
now
technically in order to cheat i'm sure
you have to talk to other [ __ ] yes
the var has come back and um you know
what because of the absolute scumbag you
are
i'm gonna have to give you the point
[Applause]
all right so we asked
princess the same thing what do you
think princess said about you
i said before that time
okay so i'mma let you know
but i was wrong
okay so basically um she said that
you're not a footballer
you're not a f-man and basically you're
financially wobbly yeah she said that
you're unstable when it comes to the
finances
okay that's not what i don't know i said
don't worry i'll tell you this
lack of funds no no no it was lack of
providing
fighting yeah providing you said you do
not
she said that one time she was on the
bus and obviously she got her purse and
you couldn't even like pat in the bus
that's what she said yeah
hey
question free
i made
you lovely women look at each other and
i said what's the one thing
what one feature would you guys think's
penny on the other lady i'm gonna go
with you e-man what do you think she
said
you're thinking about pulling out
lawyers
you know
how much will yours
[Applause]
so
i think it's uh i think it's a heist
they say you've been looking into
princesses
[Music]
question three as a judge i can reveal
that both of you were incorrect
mail said that you would say in her face
you didn't say something on the face but
you didn't say face you said it biased
because obviously looking into her soul
trying to see the inside of her through
her eyes
so he was wrong and then
princess said drip
so on round two
can we have the scores please judge
scores are in
we have
one point
on the front side
and we have a whopping
zero points
on princess and human side total out of
the two rounds are
three
it's a francaise
and one
to the criminals
[Music]
all right guys so this is round three
it's like a
crazy round anything can happen in this
round gets a bit interesting i ask you a
few questions and what i do ask you you
can say no to you can say nah i'd rather
not do that but if you do do that you'll
get the point and i'm not gonna lie you
used to
definitely need to say yes to everything
i ask because
the points are weak yeah they're lucky
okay
can you swap phones please for question
one what i want you that to do i want
you all to go to the instagram
dm please
and you thought you were stick trying to
hide it here my man is francisco
what
a friend my brother
wait
wait wait wait wait oh wait bro it's
long
what do we call this we call this
a long day
long day
long day long decade you never heard of
this francisco guy i've ever heard of
this
man's going through the highlights you
know i'm so embarrassed he's like
a message as well
so he's my man
this a friend
how come i don't know him
yeah i told you i met him
[Laughter]
how long do you say you've been together
before
four years
have you met up with this guy no
yeah i'm not talking to him that way has
he ever flirted with you i see a lot of
flirting here
yeah you like him and he's hard
would you be happy if he if you depend
the way he he responds um everything's
okay over there he's a bit quiet
everything's fine still
you ain't seen that and you don't want
to see
i actually know all right let's move
over to the what's up sir you'll be a r
him yeah
use that get the point use that get
point one
all right now over to the what's up
please this girl has a lock on her who
has a lot of
i've found three goals already what are
my days
all this year
what have you got to say for yourself
you man about um complimenting women
would you like it if princess was
complimenting man
chateau is
i sharing a cart
[Music]
wait how was your little brother how was
he sixteen sixty that makes sense that's
amazing he's sharing you know what i'm
saying she's building up his youtube if
i dm them now
and be like do you know who you're
talking to me they're gonna say you're
looking okay
yeah that's okay what about you
everything's good over here
normal francisco here
francisco is the only issue for now oh
oh damn he's an issue we've got i
thought
a man said he liked a girl's braids just
just two seconds ago two seconds and
then he's talking to a girl with braids
this is relationship girls guy you got
the wrong guy but it's your little
brother right yeah it's a little brother
a little brother what fantastic oh
that's my dog so i'm gonna put that one
right at your lips so use that i call it
that everyone's happy with that one yeah
yeah all right cool
same
i don't know what to say could you do me
a favor just listen to two of the voice
notes of her responses i just want to
see what the energy's like
no this is not about power it's
complimenting you he's throwing comfort
in that what are you gonna say about
that
i just say thank you
okay
is everyone saw what they needed to see
and heard what they needed to hear
okay
let's get the final scores in that got a
bit
tense
it's techy because because they speak in
a different language we can't see
anything too incriminating
and they was talking about power when we
pressed the voice note they were talking
about power however
ever
however started combos she did start a
convo with this man replied to comments
she did reply to love eyes love eyes i
just replied that's it oh excuse me
where are the judges over here
so she replied to love eyes
she said hey
not hi
hey wife three now just one why okay no
no
oh there was a lot of me a couple wise
thoughts
hey
sorry that's it if there's if there's
more than one why yeah no point there we
moved on
you guys vir again yeah we need a viewer
we need a video
okay so the reason why we'll go for var
is because you did catch him talking to
girls and complimenting him
but at the same time
he did say his brother has access to his
account now he is a black man and we
know
that black man it's impossible for them
to achieve doesn't work so because of
that we have to like work it out because
it's impossible that he was cheating and
his brother does have access and his
brother has access to his account yeah
so but we don't have his brother here to
confirm fully okay
oh you're ready all right cool
put it by your mic
wait it's the answer
the person
you know what i'm gonna give him i'm
gonna give him that i'm gonna give him
that point because he opted
and
to
cause
shows that yeah that shows faithfulness
apart from the one hiccup at the start
you just like passed this round with
flying colors it was shaky all the way
through and i'm not gonna lie mayo i was
rooting for you before this but now i'm
a bit disappointed but you know who am i
to judge i'm just a host
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so the scores are in
judge
what are the final scores please final
scores are
four points
[Music]
princess
[Applause]
this has been another episode of
relationship goals where we're trying to
see who the most solid couple is
this is the last one
because we've got all our couples now
the winners are going to be joining us
in the semi-final
and then
we're gonna see
who gets to the final yeah make sure you
subscribe man come on yes
how could you not
do you not do you don't want to miss
this guy don't be we need we need the
notifications on yeah click that bell
and add that bell yes click that bell
yeah and don't be disloyal like these
guys i mean don't be disloyal start
chousing
have you drunk kissed someone whilst
being in a relationship with matthew
maybe how long have you been together oh
almost two years
wow
have you done that as well no
as i said yep
[Applause]
[Music]
you